bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 22 juin
vous regardez le 7 8 le journal merci de
nous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition où comme chaque jour nous
reviendrons sur l'actualité locale
entouré de nous inviter mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite on commence avec les titres 1 le
premier jour des soldes c'est
aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 2 août un moment
très attendu par les commerçants qui
espèrent revoir leur chiffre d'affaires
à la hausse après une période de creux
en raison de la météo
reportage dans plusieurs centres
commerciaux pour voir si les clients et
pète au rendez vous faut
saint quentin en yvelines et la lèque l
agence locale de l'énergie et du climat
lance une plateforme de rénovation et
renée elle est menée rejet tic
ce guichet unique s'adresse aux saint
quentinois souhaitant se renseigner sur
les travaux de rénovation de leur
habitation et 275 millions d'euros c'est
le prix de la maison la plus chère du
monde
elle se trouve dans les yvelines à
l'ancienne nous partons nous partirons
sur la piste de son propriétaire
et c'est la délivrance pour lycéens de
terminale le bac c'est enfin terminé au
moins jusqu'aux résultats avec peut-être
les rattrapages les dernières épreuves
se sont déroulées aujourd'hui avec les
mathématiques pour les filières es et
les ailes
les scientifiques eux ont passé les
épreuves de biologie mais le répit sera
de courte durée les futurs bacheliers
doivent attendre le 5 juillet pour
connaître le verdict aujourd'hui le
stress n'était pas à l'ordre du jour
d'écouter ses élèves du lycée de vue là
roi de guyancourt il était plutôt
confiant au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas landry on sait enfin
délivré en fait je pris mon temps
j'avais largement le temps de faire il
ya des questions dures
j'ai passé j'ai confiance en moi
j'espère vous avoir une bonne réponse et
que je parle au rattrapage puisque j'ai
envie de profiter de mes vacances et
voilà j'ai passé les maths ça
franchement ça a été un je pense que je
m'en suis bien sorti et je verrai bien
là je suis confiante là je rêvais pas
trop le 5 juillet parce que je me dis tu
vas l'avoir
bon après si je n'ai pas ça va être
autre chose mais non franchement là c
est né le 5 serait un peu de stress mais
ça devrait aller
ils vont pouvoir profiter du soleil bien
sûr on leur souhaite bonne chance pour
les résultats et je vous le disais en
titre les soldes ont débuté ce mercredi
matin à 8 heures un rendez vous
incontournable pour les commerçants qui
réalise une partie importante de leur
chiffre d'affaires annuel à cette
période alors comment les centres
commerciaux du département gère-t-il ce
moment les consommateurs
s'intéresse-t-il toujours au sol nous
nous sommes rendus à one nacion paris et
parly 2 pour en savoir un peu plus
un reportage signé fanny bourdillon et
mélanie poker 8 heures c'est parti pour
le grand marathon des soldes dans ce
centre commercial athlètes des
clayes-sous-bois cette période
représente 20% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel
cette année elle s'annonce
particulièrement importante suite aux
intempéries ou les ventes étaient en
baisse
alors pour attirer les clients vers
leurs boutiques les commerçants mettent
en place des opérations spéciales
aujourd'hui on a démarré les soldes à 8h
en offrant une remise supplémentaire de
10% sur toutes les boutiques
supplémentaires sur les soldes et nous
avons offert un petit déjeuner dans tous
nos restaurants
une preuve que ces opérations marketing
fonctionne bien une heure après
l'ouverture des soldes
la fréquentation a déjà augmenté de 20%
les clients répondent présents et sont
ravis
c'est formidable on est accueilli avec
un petit déjeuner il n'y a pas trop de
monde y fait beau que du bonheur je
trouve que c'est sympa parce que ce tout
cas vous proposer le petit déjeuner
c'est super on passe un bon moment avant
attaquer les soldes donc sous peu c'est
bien très bien très calme en plus donc
c'est très agréable on a des réductions
supplémentaires en venant tous beaucoup
s'est levé tôt les ventes privées et le
e-commerce défavorise parfois les soldes
mais auch et n'ai pas d'inquiétude les
180 enseignes du centre sont confiantes
les soldes restent un rendez vous
incontournable comme le premier semestre
a été un petit peu compliqué en raison
effectivement d'un climat social chargé
d'une météo qui a été si peu clémente
forcément il ya du stock
il ya un eu envie de vendre de faire la
place par nouvelle collection et les
clients aussi envie de s'équiper pour
avant de partir en vacances donc à il ya
un enthousiasme une envie partagée
d'une façon générale on n'a pas trop à
se plaindre vu l'historique de notre
magasin on arrive à tenir nos chiffres
régulièrement et ce depuis un certain
nombre d'années pour les soldes de cet
été le panier moyen des français devrait
s'élever à 300 euros soit une
augmentation de 55 euros par rapport à
l'année dernière
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien nous accueillons plateau
jacques costil nouveau président du
lions club de montigny le bretonneux
bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors vous avez j'ai lu
me la semaine dernière président du
lions club du lion ce club pardon à la
suite de ferments romeo
alors tout d'abord qu'est-ce que le
lion's-club quelles sont ses missions
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas cette
institution alors revenons ce fleuve
ce n'est pas une secte concernant ce
qu'on peut entendre mais les personnes
des bénévoles des hommes des femmes qui
donnent de leur temps pour essayer de
monter les manifestations et ces
manifestations chaque euro gagné est
reversée aux associations locales ou
nationales selon différents critères qui
sont décidés par le club et pour
permettre sa source à ces associations
de manière à bien leur projet la
principale valeur c'est l'éthique c'est
l'écoutent
de tous c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
travaille les lorsqu'on est en réunion
on n'est pas à deux à parler il ya une
personne qui parle et on s'écoute
actuellement et ça c'est une valeur
fondamentale donc vous aider beaucoup
d'associations mais indifféremment est
ce qu'il ya des associations de
prédilection elle vous reverser à des
fonds alors lorsqu'on organise alors
lorsqu'on organise une manifestation on
annonce au préalable pour qui va être
destinés les fonds du bénéfice fait sur
la la manifestation comme la prairial
kinko hyo beaucoup de gens des environs
on sait que c'est reversés pour les
chiens guides d'aveuglés vu notamment la
robe
on leur a versé un chèque de son bureau
lorsqu'on organise harman et tu vas
avoir lieu le 22 et le 23 octobre la
sphère musulmane et et bien ça va être
destinés aux personnes handicapées aux
associations qui s'occupent des
personnes handicapées et nous avons
également une convention avec le chr ce
équinoxe donc en revient également dans
1000 euros avec linux qui est né à milan
pour les femmes violentées alors
d'organiser des initiatives pourquoi y
avait de l'argent à d'autres
associations il ya une forte
mobilisation à 50 on a vu aussi à
montigny le bretonneux
c'est le club de saint quentin on manque
de personnes ont une très honnête reste
personne il faudrait qu'on se renforce
de cinq six personnes ce serait bien
parce que quand il faut aussi monter les
grilles armes année
c'est pour un club qui lui qui a plutôt
tendance à dire ça serait mieux pouvoir
se rajeunit on à dire quoi parce que on
a été contacté par l'estac a laissé sa
claque et 1000 écoles d'ingénieurs et on
va peut-être arriver à recréer un club
léo donc voilà du sang neuf tu peux
arriver dans ce club ce serait
intéressant et on a un autre projet qui
s'appelle prêt pour la vie qui aide aux
personnes qui deviendra club par une
chaîne aux locaux et qui qui se sont eux
mêmes qui ont suivi un cursus écologique
pour soutenir les perses les licences
aignan où les éducateurs dans les
centres de loisirs
lorsque il ya des petits jeunes qui
perturbe un peu qu'ils sont un peu lents
ou et et donc qu'ils aident à apporter
une réponse à cette à ces actes de
violence de l'estaca quelles sont les
missions des bénévoles ou en ce club sur
la certains souhaitent vous rejoindre
chacun trouve sa place dans ce qu'ils
souhaitent
il choisit ce concrètement si il aime
les purs et les jardins et qu' il
souhaite porter un peu de ton temps sur
cette manifestation à l'eswc a visité
des manifestations identiques il choisir
quelques commerces sans qui pourrait
venir nous rejoindre si c'est d'un côté
dollar man et il voit pas trop où un
sculpteur et nous lire va tient il ya
passé quelque chose
elle serait heureux de cette personne et
armani c'est ce qui a servi également
mais ce que toutes les les
les tabliers de sable odin âgées
handicap et le no se va également payer
la voiture
le giron l'icapp dernier vous avez
reverser donc plusieurs chèques à
dénonciation que le cas donc la chine de
l'équinoxe
il y à des associations qui vont vous
tenir à coeur je sais que vous êtes
également président de la fft
l'association pour la recherche sur la
trisomie 21
on voulait voilà il va y avoir peut-être
des initiatives dans ce sens alors à
titre personnel j'aimerais éviter que le
mélange les ensuite à la vérité c'est
que le président sortant a souhaité
reverser 1500 euros à la frc locale
lafferty 78 que nous allons créer en
février 2014
mais moi à titre personnel le voilà j'ai
une certaine éthique aussi et donc ne
n'y aura pas durant ce mandat là cette
année n'a d'argent reversés à la fft
parce que le jeu je suis certaine
investissait beaucoup d'encre dans les
associations donc à la salle des fêtes
le président maintenant le lion scop ça
fait 13 ans que quand vous êtes donc
bénévoles aubry cela qu'est ce que ça
représente pour vous eh bien je me suis
engagé dans le handicap parce que j'ai
pu toucher par la naissance de deux
enfants handicapés ils ont que j'ai été
adjoint au maire en charge du handicap
de 80 à 95 et en 2003 j'ai écrit un
livre qui s'appelait réflexion sur le
handicap et j'ai vu lors d'une dédicace
une personne ne venait me voir me dis
tiens voilà je suis disposé à jouer
président du lions club de montigny est
ce que vous pourriez passer les dix cas
ces volumes donc je suis allé à la
rencontre de ces gens de ces personnes
et j'ai vu que finalement on défendre la
même cause
donc plus cette habitation je me sens
redevable vis-à-vis de ces gens là et je
me suis dit voilà lancés dans cette
aventure dans cette belle aventure
un club d'amis ou vraiment tout et on
est vraiment maintenant des hommes et
des vins à l'époque il y avait que des
hommes masqués la mixité est donc et est
normalement la la la la personne qui
sera président l'april à plusieurs
présidents sera une femme d'ailleurs
rapidement sous votre présence et
l'instant voilà c'est vous qui êtes en
charge de ça il va y avoir du nouveau au
lion ce club vous allez peut-être de
nouvelles dynamiques des projets
peut-être spécifiques alors tous les je
vais pas tout bousculer
ces manifestations qui sont déjà en
place qui commence à être connu c'est
pas le moment tout changer mais 2017
c'est le centième anniversaire de la
création du club donc je vais essayer
avec les maires et s'étend vers l'elysée
une journée spéciale sans son lot c'est
important la prochain événement c'est en
octobre
comment est bien les gens qui viennent
et on en sera une petite somme
hélas cette petite somme multipliée par
le nombre de ses adhérents jeu rivière
et tous les artistes qui viennent le
plus place et tout est reversée je sais
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure aux
associations locales qui qui souhaite
comme vous nous avons aidé du fun pour
tous et merci beaucoup à jax teller
voilà un rendez vous pour un mélange
cadre de montigné le breton ce sera en
octobre
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
que moi tu meurs fut tout autre sujet à
présent la demeure la plus chère du
monde se trouve dans les yvelines à
l'ancienne et elle vaut 275 millions
d'euros c'est un cas important leur
propriétaire dont l'identité est tenue
secrète bénéficiera d'un terrain de 23
hectares et d'un château moderne de 5000
m² michael almy d'euros et aller y jeter
un oeil pour nous regarder derrière ses
grilles de plusieurs mètres d'eau situé
chemin de bellevue et à louveciennes se
cache la maison la plus chère du monde
bâti sur le modèle du château de
vaux-le-vicomte la demeure privée
construite en 2011 a été vendu 275
millions d'euros
l'acheteur bénéficie de 23 hectares de
terrain est un château moderne de 5000
mètres carrés équipée d'une salle de
cinéma de mobilier du xviie siècle et de
plusieurs piscines
c'était une alliance en quelque sorte
des techniques de construction moderne
en utilisant notamment le béton armé sur
lequel ont été recouverts ont été placés
les pierres qui étaient issues de
carrières qui étaient les mêmes que
celles qu'on avait utilisé pour des
châteaux prestigieux comme évidemment le
château de versailles
dans la ville les 7200 habitants sont
partagés sur cette acquisition là je
suis dans la science fiction là quand
vous me parlez de ce château etc
donc c'est difficile de sortir des mots
et de s'exprimer à ce sujet là vous
pouvez prendre n'importe quel dossier de
moi je crois qu'ils sont ils sont comme
moi sont dans le même état quoi voilà on
est plus plus terre à terre il ya
d'autres choses qui me font rêver moi et
d'autres choses qui me font rêver sans
avoir autant de voix de châteaurenaud un
bungalow ça me fait rêver vous voyez
gens pensent que ça a été un un bon coup
médiatique pour faire valoriser le
village on a connu au niveau national
loup sienne qui est un joli petit
village de son côté la vie ne touchera
pas de pactole suite à cette vente la
transaction se fait uniquement avec des
sociétés civiles immobilières les
propriétés payeront seulement la taxe
d'habitation
ça aurait été un bol d'air pour notre
commune de recevoir un droit de mutation
quand même très conséquents puisque on
avait calculé qui dépassaient le million
d'euros l'identité du propriétaire est
toujours tenue secrète selon les proches
du dossier il s'agirait d'un particulier
originaire du moyen-orient
l'acheteur n'aurait toujours pas posé sa
valise dans son château moderne de
louveciennes depuis son acquisition
et comme tous les mercredis c'est votre
rendez vous habituels la chronique
environnement cette semaine il sera
question de rénovation énergétique ce
lundi l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines et l'agencé locale de
l'énergie et du climat ont lancé une
plateforme à destination des
particuliers mais aussi des
professionnels
mélanie poquet nous a rejoint en plateau
pour nous la présenter bonsoir avait
magnifié consorts florame la plateforme
elle s'appelle repères habitat elle
s'inscrit dans la loi de transition
énergétique
là il s'agit d'un service public de la
performance énergétique de l'habitat
ce qui a motivé les acteurs locaux à
lancer cette plateforme c'est le manque
de lien qui peut y avoir parfois entre
les porteurs de projets les entreprises
et les particuliers
il s'agit avant tout d'un service
supplémentaire à l'espace info énergie
proposé notamment par l'ex saint quentin
qui se trouve actuellement à manille les
amants à côté de l'ancienne maison de
l'environnement
je propose d'écouter alexandrins rosetti
jst présidente de l'agglomération
délégué à l'habitat elle était au micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude
il ya quelques années en 2012 a été mis
en place le plus le prêt par exemple de
caméras thermiques
ça permet de voir un petit peu où sont
les difficultés dans sa propriété
mais là pour aller un petit peu au-delà
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire et ce que
c'est de l'isolation extérieure est ce
que c'est lise le toit à refaire voilà
tout ça on a besoin de conseils
l'idée c'est que n'importe quelle
entreprise peut répondre mais qu'on aide
à analyser les deux vies parce qu'on
sait très bien que quand on fait faire
des devis bas on en a plusieurs et c'est
pas toujours facile de comprendre
techniquement quelle est la meilleure
solution pour qu'il n'est pas question
de mettre des entreprises de côté mais
par contre qu'il faut qu'elles répondent
aux critères bien sûr
sont nécessaires alors la rénovation
énergétique ce sont les travaux que l'on
peut engager dans un logement pour qu'il
y ait notamment un minimum de pertes de
chaleur pertes aux charges que dans une
maison
ça peut venir de différents endroits
pour s'en rendre compte je vous propose
qu'on regarde cette infographie dans une
maison non mal isolés les faits les
pavés s'échapper jusqu'à 15% de chaleur
les murs eux de 20 à 25% et les plus
grosses fuites on le voit peuvent
provenir du toit avec 25 à 30 % de
pertes
franck sentiers directeur de la lègue
nous expliquent l'impact que peut avoir
une rénovation énergétique le bâtiment
et consomment plus de 40% en fait de
l'énergie en france donc réduire la
consommation énergétique des logements
c'est indispensable si on veut
effectivement réduire les consommations
d'énergie globale en france
et du coup les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre façon à pouvoir lutter contre
le changement climatique alors repères
habitat c'est un guichet en guichet
unique pour les gens qui souhaitent
rénover leur maison leur propriété elle
se découpe en trois pôles conseil
travaux et financement elle est à
destination de quel public la nuit elle
concerne en fait tous les saint
quentinois qui seraient intéressés je le
disais elle les met en relation
professionnels et particuliers vous
parlez de trois pôles
il y a aussi trois parties les
particuliers les conseils syndicaux et
les professionnels pour les particuliers
elle permet d'obtenir aussi des conseils
sur ce qui peut être fait dans une
habitation
les travaux conseiller en fonction des
analyses ou des devis réalisés mais
aussi les financements auxquels les
propriétaires peuvent prétendre
puisqu'il existe des aides du
département ou de l'agglomération et que
le programme habiter mieux il existe
aussi des crédits d'impôt et des éco ptz
des prêts à taux zéro elle va donc aider
les particuliers mais elle permet aussi
une meilleure visibilité pour les
entreprises c'est le cas de celle de
pascal rambeau il est gérant d'une
entreprise de 45 personnes sur 50 ha en
oliviers et les spécialisée dans les
les agrandissements et notamment la
rénovation énergétique
il ya un deuxième point positif pour
nous qui travaillons en réseau avec des
partenaires
de l'agglomération avec d'autres
entreprises avec des bureaux d'études
avec des banques qui apporte du
financement puisque c'est tous ensemble
que un package secret pour résoudre
l'ensemble des conditions nécessaires à
au démarrage des travaux
lorsqu'il faut savoir avec repères
habitat c'est que c'est un service sur
le long terme puisque les membres de la
lègue suivront les projets pas à pas
même une fois les travaux terminés exact
chaque moment clé des projets et travaux
seront contrôlés par la lèque il y aura
aussi un retour sur les travaux engagés
c'est un moyen de donner confiance aussi
à ceux qui voudraient s'engager plus
tard sur des rénovations la rénovation
énergétique étant un domaine un peu
complexe on peut parfois craindre des
escroqueries ou même un nombre
d'informations se dire qu'on aurait pu
faire autre chose donc il faut savoir
que pour être contrôlés les entreprises
sont proposés par nom par la plateforme
ont signé lundi une charte qui est une
sorte de label il ya déjà des critères
on va dire objectifs comme la mention
hergé a reconnu garant de
l'environnement qui est indispensable
pour pouvoir que les particuliers
puissent bénéficier des aides
financières finalement et puis après
effectivement on compte sur les retours
d'expérience des premiers projets qui
donc permettront de valider le fait que
c'est des entreprises performantes et
donc ils donneront confiance aux futurs
au foot personnes qui viendront faire
des travaux après donc depuis lundi et
son lancement la plateforme est
accessible à tous sur le site suivant
www.repere.org habitat.fr il suffit de
vous inscrire pour trouver des conseils
ou lancer dès aujourd'hui dès
aujourd'hui votre projet le plan de
rénovation énergétique de l'habitat
présenté par le président de la
république en mars 2013 vise à atteindre
l'objectif de diminution de 38 % des
consommations d'énergie du secteur du
bâtiment à l'horizon 2020 merci beaucoup
mais la niche autre sujet à présent les
sapeurs pompiers étaient à l'honneur
samedi 18 juin à montigny le bretonneux
le centre de secours a ouvert ses portes
au public pour un week-end portes
ouvertes entre 2500 et 3000 personnes se
sont rendues à ces journées où les
combattants du feu sont revenus sur leur
histoire les différentes missions des
sapeurs pompiers du
19e siècle à nos jours avec des
démonstrations assez impressionnantes
comme vous le montre nicolas landry et
mélanie poké 22 juin 1906 un feu se
déclare à montigny le bretonneux
les sapeurs-pompiers unis montrent un
interviennent avec une pompe à bras
une reconstitution historique d'une
extinction d'un incendie en ce début de
xxème siècle nous avons donc procédé à
l'extinction d'une petite maisonnette
confectionner maison au moyen de
sapeurs-pompiers en costumes d'époque et
qui ont mis en oeuvre une pompe à bras
et nous avons sollicité comme à l'époque
le public pour créer la chaîne humaine
permettant l'alimentation en eau de la
pompe à bras 2500 à 3000 personnes sont
venues découvrir le centre de secours de
montigny le bretonneux lors des portes
ouvertes ce samedi 18 juin
différents moyens d'extinction des
incendies du dix neuvième siècle à nos
jours ont été présentées à travers des
démonstrations
objectif découvrir l'évolution des
techniques et des tenues des soldats du
feu des simulations suivi de près par
les plus jeunes c'est aussi un des
objectifs de la journée portes ouvertes
c'est de créer des vocations parmi ces
parmi ces enfants parmi les jeunes des
ateliers ont permis aux enfants de
s'essayer aux activités des pompiers
comme le secours aux animaux pris en
charge par cinq sapeurs pompiers du
groupe animalier à montigny le
bretonneux une mission occasionnels peu
connu du public dans le cadre de la
protection des personnes de
l'environnement et
des meubles l'animal a une place
particulière au sein de nos
nos communautés ce qui fait que on doit
lui porter assistance également le
secourisme animalier représente moins de
8% de l'activité avec plus de 6400
intervention en 2015 le centre de
secours de montigny le bretonneux se
classe au troisième rang en termes
d'activité opérationnelle technologie à
présent lundi s'est terminée
l'exposition de quatrième défi et
technologiques et départementales 200
écoles des yvelines se sont rassemblés
autour du thème entre équilibré et
levier l'objectif la réalisation d'une
oeuvre remplissons un cahier des charges
bien précis les élèves des petites
sections devait bâtir une tour dans des
matériaux recyclables et ceux de l'école
primaire devaient construire un objet
pouvant soulever une masse de 300 g
pendant 10 secondes
au total ces 170 oeuvres qui ont été
exposés à la commanderie des templiers
d'elancourt un défi organisé par
l'atelier des séances de saint quentin
en yvelines
écoutez les précisions recueillies par
camille lambert se défient donc
a pour principal objectif de faire
travailler les élèves en sciences et
notamment de lait de les mettre dans une
démarche d'investigation donc la
démarche de chercheurs scientifiques
l'important finalement c'est peut-être
pas forcément d'arriver à remplir
définitivement cahier des charges mais
c'est d'avoir mis les élèves dans une
démarche de réflexion hier soir saint
quentin en yvelines à célébrer l'arrivée
de l'été avec la fête de la musique de
nombreux événements gratuits étaient
proposés aux habitants et cela jusqu'à
midi camille que jusqu'à minuit par bus
camille lambert est allé faire un tour
du côté de plaisir et de montigny le
bretonneux ou la programmation était
très varié regarder
à
concert rock jazz au chorale saint
quentin en yvelines a fêté la musique
mardi 21 juin à la clé des champs de
plaisir le début de soirée était
consacrée aux élèves du conservatoire de
la ville
petits et grands ont pu laisser libre
cours à leur âme d'artiste
on ouvre la scène un petit peu à
différentes catégories aux cultures
musicales
d'année en année on varie aussi évident
et c'est laissé à chacun libre
expression je dirais devenir je découvre
des nouvelles la musique j'aime bien
voir les autres faire de la musique et
couvrir c'est super sympa en plus on est
à l'abri cette année elle n'avait pas à
l'extérieur avec la pluie donc un petit
cadre très agréable à montigny le
bretonneux la ville a fait le pari de
conserver l'événement en extérieur au
centre sportif pierre de coubertin une
zumba géante était organisée pour
s'échauffer en musique avec un
professeur c'était génial c'est ok moi
on fait mais vous d amour et puis on
s'éclate ça fait du bien
à bien écouter on est venus fêter la
fête de la musique en famille la
première fête de la musique de
mademoiselle
ensemble de saxophones ou orchestre de
seine ont été installés jusqu'à minuit
les artistes de la ville ont rythmé la
soirée
on va avoir une succession de groupes
essentiellement des groupes qui émane du
conservatoire de musique mais également
des groupes locaux qui bénéficié de nos
studios de répétition une au studio
d'enregistrement
mise en place en france en 1983 la fête
de la musique continue de faire vibrer
cette année encore 120 pays l'ont
célébré
et nous nous quittons donc en musique
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous retrouve
demain pour une nouvelle édition du
journal je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée